In many workplaces, there are rules
that are completely unspoken.
Understanding them is crucial for success,
and yet you won't find them
in your employee handbook.
Unless you're lucky enough
to have a mentor or manager
who pulls you aside to help,
you just kind of have to figure
them out on your own.
[The Way We Work]
Starting a new job can feel
like starting at a new school.
You're meeting new people,
you're getting thrown
into unfamiliar situations,
and you’re constantly wondering:
What does everyone think of me?
But whether you're starting
your first job ever
or just starting a new role,
making a great impression
doesn't have to be so scary.
It all comes down to deciphering
those unspoken rules
and demonstrating
what I call the three Cs:
competence, commitment and compatibility.
The first C is competence.
On day one, your new colleagues
are probably looking at you
and thinking: Can you do your job?
The way to convince others,
not to mention yourself,
that yes, you can,
is to show your homework
and to give others something to react to.
Let’s say it’s your first day,
and it’s utter chaos.
People are forwarding you messages
with nothing more
than a "See below" at the top
and pulling you into meetings
without any notice or context.
Your manager just gave you a task,
and two minutes in
you're already confused.
Instead of going back to them
right away and saying,
“I don’t know what to do next, help!”
Or doing what I did,
which is not asking questions at all,
think about a similar task
that you tried in a previous job,
in school or just for yourself.
What steps did you take then?
Then make your best guess
and just give it a try.
Then go back to your manager and say,
“I’m working on X,
and I'm not quite sure of what to do next.
I've taken X steps and spoken to so-and-so
and I understand this part,
but I'm still unclear
about this other part.
What do you think about this approach?"
No, I'm not suggesting
that you fake it till you make it,
but what I am suggesting is that you try
until you can't try anymore.
Time matters, though,
so give yourself a limit.
And depending on your deadline,
figuring things out on your own.
Then ask and then learn
from what others tell you.
It's your first bit of knowledge
around how things work here.
The second C is commitment.
Besides looking to see
if you can do your job,
your colleagues are also looking
to see if you're dedicated.
During your first week in a new job,
try asking your manager
questions about expectations.
My favorites are one,
what are my top priorities in this role?
Two, how would you like to communicate
day-to-day and week-to-week?
And three, what have
your highest performers done
that you'd suggest that I do too?
For your peers, try to go more casual.
In your first few days,
your manager will be probably, or well,
at least hopefully,
taking you around and introducing you
to your other teammates.
In those moments,
think about how you can transform
some of those "Hi's" into conversations
and then those conversations
into relationships.
One option is to ask
how others' weeks are going.
For those you really get along with,
try involving them in your work
and maybe even your life
with phrases like,
“Oh, I’d love to get your input on A.”
Or “Could I get your advice on B?”
These can all go a long way
in deepening a relationship.
The third C, it's compatibility.
Every time a new person joins a team,
the others on it want to know:
Will you get along with us?
By initiating conversations,
you're already expressing compatibility.
But while you're at it,
use this time to try and identify
who's in charge of what
or what I call “invisible swim lanes.”
Let's say you've just started
a new remote job.
First, ask your manager
if there's an org chart.
It's a diagram showing
who reports to whom.
And if there is one, amazing.
But formal job titles and reporting lines
can only tell you so much
about how things really work.
So when you're in meetings
and group chats, pay attention.
What's each person's role?
Who reports to whom?
Who's on whose side, who commands respect,
which behaviors get rewarded
and which behaviors get punished?
Understanding these norms,
loyalties, power brokers
and swim lanes
is what people are really referring to
when they say that it’s important
to understand a team’s “culture.”
And by the way, while you're
mapping out these swim lanes,
look around to see if there's any
swim lane that might be unoccupied
or in other words,
what tasks might be available
that aren't currently being done
that can help your team accomplish
more, better, faster, cheaper, safer,
more securely.
By doing this,
you'll show that you're competent
enough to spot gaps,
committed enough to fill them
and compatible enough to not overstep.
Here’s the reality of starting a new job.
Doing your job is only part of it.
The rest is about how
you get along with other people.
But as much as we've been talking
about others sizing you up,
don't forget to do the same.
Is this an environment where you can
flourish and do your best work?
Can you see yourself getting
along with your coworkers?
Is this even work you're excited to do?
Every job is a two-way street.
You can do well
only if you want to do well.
And if you're set up to do well.
So look around, reflect
and be honest with yourself
about whether this
is a good place for you.